[ Up-tempo music plays ]
-Hey, everybody.
We referred to
Camilla Parker Bowles
as the queen.
She is the queen consort.
"Consort," of course, is
British slang
[British accent]
for "home-wrecker"!
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ] Buffalo wings
are served with blue cheese,
not ranch dressing,
but they are always eaten
with regret.
[ Laughter ]
I said, if the word
"comptroller"
was pronounced "controller,"
then "computer" would be
pronounced "con-puter."
I blew my own joke.
"Joke."
[ Laughter ]
A bunch of you said,
"If 'comptrol' is 'control,'
that means the 'M-P' should
be pronounced as an 'N,'
which means 'computer'
would be con-uter.'"
[ Laughter ]
You guys got it right.
I got it wrong.
What can I say?
I'm an ass-t.
[ Laughter ]
I have an exciting update
about my soon-to-be-produced
Broadway show, "Cicada, Cicada."
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to give anything
away,
but the update regards costumes.
[ Laughter ]
You do not use quarters
at Dave & Buster's.
You need a card.
I think I have one here.
There we go.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sniffles ]
[ Sighs ]
I pronounced
the toilet paper brand
Charmin "Charr-min"
in "You're Burnt,"
which led some of you
to the conclusion
that I don't use Charmin.
I must use
an even-fancier toilet paper.
How dare you?
[ Laughter ]
Toi-- Toilet paper.
I got a bidet filled
with cham-pagne.
[ Laughter ]
[ Blows ]
[ Sighs ]
[ Laughter ]
I was told popes can't have kids
because they're celibate.
I didn't know that.
Also, do they know that?
[ Laughter ]
I'm trying to start a...
"Oc-TAG-o-nal,"
not "oc-ta-GON-al."
The guy in the clip
said it wrong,
and then I said it wrong,
and I'm not going to
wear that one.
Okay?
[ Laughter ]
We said,
you know, there was
Super Bowl ads for Jesus.
And we said Jesus didn't need
a Super Bowl commercial,
because, you know,
He doesn't need marketing.
He did one sermon
2,000 years ago,
and people are still
talking about Him.
We were referring
to the Sermon on the Mount.
He also did
a Sermon on the Plain,
which we hear about way less
because, I guess, it was
just, like,
a terrible sound system.
[ Laughter ]
Like, everyone in the back
was like...
[ Laughter ]
They had to do a --
I guess there were, like,
a ton of refunds.
Don't get me wrong.
There are still
people out there --
you know the kind of fans --
they were like,
"No, the Sermon on the Plain
is the best one."
And they're like, "Oh, the --"
You know?
[ Laughter ]
Bandwagon people.
"They'll sell you on Mount,
but Plain..."
It's like people
who think, like, "Nebraska"
is Springsteen's best album.
Good album, but...
"Play 'Mansion on the Hill'!"
You know those people
at concerts?
Like, "Dude, he's not gonna."
Uh...
we said Herschel Walker
was famous
for thinking vampires were cool.
A lot of you said he was famous
for playing football.
And I was like, "Oh, it was
that Herschel Walker?"
[ Laughter ]
Explains a lot.
Oh!
[ Laughter ]
Not this week, but last week,
we said,
Mike Lindell is so loud,
you can hear his voice
inside a seashell.
When we took out something,
we called it a seashell.
It was not -- I was corrected --
it was a conch.
And, um...
[ Laughter ]
Hollywood, though,
knows a hit when they see one.
And, uh, we got clearance
from the studio
to make a big announcement
about a children's film.
Everybody should
keep their eye out for...
"Lindell, the Shell
With Boots On."
[ Laughter ]
[ Grunts ]
I said you should never drink
your own urine in the desert.
I should have clarified.
It's totally fine
to drink someone else's.
[ Laughter ]
So never drink your-in,
but you can drink their-in.
[ Laughter ]
There's a Joycean amount
of wordplay on this show.
[ Laughter ]
Joyce is our receptionist.
She's a lot.
"Hey, Seth, how much does
a pirate pay for corn?"
"Not now, Joyce. Just not now."
"A buccaneer."
[ Laughter ]
"Do I have any calls?
Did I have any calls today,
Joyce?"
"Oh, it looks like
I knocked the receiver off."
[ Laughter ]
"Shucks.
That's what the pirate said
when he couldn't afford
the corn."
[ Laughter ]
I swear, it's lucky
you're Lorne's mistress, Joyce."
Joking. I'm joking.
I got to say I'm joking,
'cause these go online
at, like, 1:00 a.m.
Usually get my first text
from Lorne
about his favorite parts
at, like, 1:15.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
"I thought Nebraska
should have gotten more."
[ Laughter ]
[ Blows ]
I had a cold last week,
and someone suggested,
when I have a cold,
Wally should fill in,
adding, "You're
not getting any younger.
It would be good to have
someone else with experience
should something happen to you."
Good point.
If I move on, no one better
to jump-start the youth movement
than Wally.
[ Laughter ]
Wally is very -- very healthy,
it should be noted.
Probably from, like,
making a fortune
doing this all day.
[ Laughter ]
He told me, his last physical,
his doctor said
he had the stamina
of a man half his age
and the rotator cuff
of a thousand-year-old.
[ Laughter ]
Speaking of Wally,
I did not give credit
where credit was due.
We talked about
this piece of art,
where the joke was
that Mac Tonight
had impregnated my wife.
And I didn't notice
that Wally's in the back
of this photo,
holding up a cue card
that says, "Mac Roolz."
-[ Chuckles ]
-Also, someone wrote
in the comments,
"Seth's wife is hot."
Very nice. True.
Couldn't leave it at that,
though.
The jackals.
The joke that completely
ruined the sentiment
with the next thing they wrote,
and it was only one word.
They wrote one word
that completely ruined my high
from "Seth's wife is hot."
Want to guess
what the one word was?
"Why?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Blows ]
We've received
a lot of really incredible
Mac Tonight fan art,
to the point that if you were
working on something at home,
I'm pretty sure you'd want it
to be very good
before you sent it in.
We've seen some
real craftsmanship thus far.
On the other hand,
maybe like, "I'll mail it."
[ Laughter ]
Made me so happy.
I want to thank
whoever sent that in.
Oh, we, um -- "A Closer Look,"
we had two jokes about Joe Biden
quoting Taylor Swift lyrics,
and a lot of people were upset
that we did not follow
the rule of threes,
the age-old rule in comedy
that you should
call back something twice
to make it a total of three.
And someone said,
"The rule of twos --
you should try to bring
the rule of twos into fashion."
And they made me this.
This is a 2-inch rule.
That's the rule of twos.
[ Laughter ]
I'm going to put that over here.
Rule of threes, for example --
we've done that...
severed doll-head thing
three times.
So that's over.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sniffles ]
A gentleman named Mark sent me
a wedding invitation.
He's marrying, uh,
who, he made it sound,
a beautiful woman named Jessica,
who, um, is a real fan
of "Corrections."
He said, "Look, I know you can't
make it to my wedding.
It would be really nice.
It'd mean a lot to her
if you would mention us on air."
And I will say,
a few too many times,
he said things like,
"She thinks
you're a comedic genius."
And then, in parentheses,
he'd write,
"Her words, not mine."
[ Laughter ]
Oh, I -- I, uh, stumbled
on Bill Clinton's name.
A lot of people thought
I said "Bill Kitten."
[ Laughter ]
Remember our short-lived
animated show on Hulu?
"Bill Kitten"?
It wasn't -- It had a moment.
[ Laughter ]
"I did not put my claws
on that ottoman."
[ Laughter ]
Pretty good segue
to "Animal Flubs," guys.
[ Laughter ]
Probably should have cut
"Bill Kitten,"
but it was the segue.
[ Sniffles ]
Can't just do "Animal Flubs"
cold.
[ Laughter ]
Before we get to "Animal Flubs,"
this is very embarrassing.
There was a flub
in the opening song,
and that's just --
to have a flub in a song
that's all about
addressing flubs,
well, you can't stand for that.
In the -- In the song,
the animals spell out "flubs,"
and the eagle says
the letter "B."
And a bunch of you said,
"An eagle doesn't have lips
and couldn't make a 'B' sound."
And it was just
so gutting to read,
'cause the rest of it holds up.
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, we went back
in the studio, we rerecorded it.
See if you can
tell the difference.
-♪ Animal Flubs, Animal Flubs ♪
♪ It's time to take a look
at some Animal Flubs ♪
♪ From the birds to the bees
to the baby bear cubs ♪
♪ It's time for Animal Flubs ♪
-F...
-L...
-U...
-Aaah!
-S.
♪ Are the five letters ♪
♪ You use ♪
♪ To spell "flubs" ♪
♪ Animal Flubs? ♪
[ Laughter ]
Cut it down a little, too.
A lot of you said
you like the long version,
but like two or three people
said they hated it.
And you know,
"Corrections" has never been
about making people happy.
It's always been kowtowing
to the miserable joy-eaters.
[ Laughter ]
It was time for "Animal Flubs."
You heard 'em.
Baby koalas are called joeys,
which is dumb.
I mean, Australia,
why you got to name --
You got two famous animals,
kangaroos and koalas,
and both their babies
are called joeys.
Come on.
That would be like
someone saying,
"We should give
Superman a sidekick."
"Great idea.
What will we call him?"
"Robin."
[ Laughter ]
I'm given up on
the pronunciation of "emu."
Just don't think
it's gonna happen.
I'm gonna call it
an Australian ostrich.
A.K.A. "ostrich."
That doesn't work.
[ Laughter ]
[ Sighs ]
Oh, whales aren't --
Orcas aren't whales.
They're dolphins.
A lot of people
make that mistake
'cause they're known
as killer whales.
They should be called
whale killers.
Ancient sailors
gave them that name
because they would see them
sort of hunting
and preying on larger whales.
And when I was a kid,
I wished they'd
call them whale killers,
because at least you know then
who their victims
are supposed to be.
And with killer whales,
you don't.
If they'd been whale killers,
I wouldn't have
[Bleep] my pants
every time I went to SeaWorld.
[ Laughter ]
This has been "Animal Flubs."
-♪ Animal Flubs ♪
-Oh. Oh, God.
Oh, God, no.
-What's wrong, Koala?
-Somebody do something.
-Aah. Aaah.
-[ Screams ]
-Seven days.
[ Laughter ]
That's the end of it.
Oh, wait, where'd I go?
Oh, there I am.
Okay, uh, last but not least,
"Cicada, Cicada" news.
Good news first.
We got the prototype
for the cicada's headpiece.
It looks excellent.
Bad news.
It's, like, super [Bleep] hot.
[ Laughter ]